[Música]
llegó el momento hablar de salud en
directo américa para ello ya está
conmigo en el estudio más romeros a la
mar feliz viernes bienvenida buen día
todavía existen interrogantes alrededor
de los efectos de la vacuna contra el
hobbit 19 que tiene esto en el ciclo
menstrual de las personas que sabemos al
respecto más pues antes que nada lo más
importante es que seamos honestos y que
digamos que las respuestas a estos
interrogantes nosotros no las tenemos y
que de hecho no nos corresponde tampoco
responderlas todas sino a la comunidad
científica y ala investigativa pero
bueno sabemos que cada vez hay más voces
que denuncian haber sufrido algún tipo
de cambio en su ciclo menstrual después
de haber recibido la vacuna contra el
commit 19 y para escuchar precisamente
estas voces hicimos un llamado en redes
sociales para saber pues qué es lo que
estaba preocupando a las mujeres de las
personas que menstrúan recibimos un
testimonio particularmente de una mujer
que explicaba que tuvo sangrado durante
semanas después de la vacuna que tenía
igual condiciones preexistentes que
podían también explicar eso pero que a
mí me pareció muy significativo para
explicar como la confusión que muchas de
nosotras sentimos al respecto de este
tema
yo realmente nunca le mencioné a la
ginecóloga ni le pregunté si creía que
la vacuna podría tener alguna relación
pues no lo pensé ni siquiera este nunca
fue un tema que tocáramos en la consulta
pero se me ocurrió preguntarme sobre
esto más recientemente después de leer
varios posts en instagram de medios de
comunicación o colectivas feministas que
plantearán preguntas frente al hecho de
que no existieran análisis sobre el
impacto de las vacunas sobre la salud
menstrual
este es uno de los muchos comentarios
que hemos recibido son más de 500 en
varias redes sociales lo pueden seguir
viendo igual en instagram si quieren
sumarse al debate en un post que
publicamos la semana pasada y algunos de
los que hemos recibido por ejemplo como
pueden ver nos hablan desde que no han
sufrido ningún cambio en el ciclo
menstrual de que todo sigue en orden
hasta cambios bastante radicales como
mujeres que estaban en el periodo por
ejemplo de la menopausia ya que les
volvió a llegar la regla después de
recibir la vacuna como como comentamos
esto no es la sustitución de ningún
estudio de ningún informe médico pero si
nos sirve para saber que hay que esto se
está reportando que hay varios casos y
que pues que tenemos que hablar de estos
aún así es comprendo totalmente
comprensible marc ahora es puede leer
todos estos comentarios que conclusiones
podemos extraer claro no sólo de leerlos
sino también de contrastar los con con
ginecólogos que han recibido quejas en
sus consultas con otros informes
periodísticos que han hablado de la
misma materia podemos concluir que hay
tres cambios que son los más
generalizados uno son las
irregularidades desde adelanto de hasta
retrasos en el ciclo menstrual el
segundo es un aumento del dolor y
también del síndrome premenstrual y el
tercero son el cambios en el flujo en el
sangrado en general se denuncia como un
flujo más abundante más sangrado en el
periodo pero también hay gente que ha
dicho lo contrario estos son como los
tres en los tres efectos en los que
podemos agrupar los testimonios que
hemos recibido y también los que hemos
ido recibiendo hablamos con una
ginecóloga con marcela félix ella es kim
ecóloga y es obstetra también ahorita la
escucharemos lo primero que nos explicó
igualmente es que hay muchísimas cosas
que pueden que pueden afectar el ciclo
menstrual puede ser el estrés un cambio
de vida cosas que también se relacionan
de hecho con la pandemia de kobe 19 que
por lo tanto es difícil saber que se
puede atribuir a la vacuna y que no pero
en concreto nos habló de una cosa y es
que la respuesta inmune en los cuerpos
también puede tener efectos en el
complejo el sistema hormonal que regulan
los ciclos menstruales y que ahí podría
estar la clave que explique estos
cambios de escuchemos la
no está todavía bien dilucidado el
mecanismo por el cual puede verse
alterado el ciclo menstrual en una
respuesta inmune sin embargo lo que uno
podría de tanto conjeturar es que el
cuerpo o el sistema se concentra en dar
respuesta a ese despertar de la
inmunidad ya sea la inmunidad natural
con una infección ya sea la inmunidad en
respuesta a una vacuna y deja un poco de
lado otros otros
funciones un poco menos importantes en
este momento como podría ser la
regulación del sucre mensual como decía
la doctora entonces esto también podría
explicar por qué hay mujeres que dicen
que les ha cambiado el periodo entre
ellas me incluyo después del contagio de
kobe no sólo después de la vacuna y la
clave como decíamos puede estar en esta
respuesta inmune que esperamos que se
pueda estudiar mejor para para saber qué
es lo que pasa en nuestros cuerpos ojalá
y estar más tranquilas y con respecto a
la tranquilidad mar yo quiero
preguntarle si entonces hay motivos para
alarmarse me alegra que preguntas eso
porque hay personas en redes sociales
que nos han acusado un poco de
alarmistas al estar hablando de esto sin
unos estudios sin unos datos entonces
vamos a dejar tres cosas claras desde el
principio 1 no hay ningún estudio que
vincule las vacunas del coi 19 con
cambios en el ciclo menstrual esto de
digámoslo de entrada no existen esos
estudios segundo todos los cambios
excepto algunos casos muy puntuales
parecen ser de corto plazo es decir que
se regula todo de nuevo al cabo de unos
pocos meses y tercero la importancia
también de cortar conoce algunas
noticias falsas que hablan de los
efectos de la vacuna en mujeres
embarazadas o que hablan incluso de que
pueden infertilidad eso no es cierto en
ninguno de los dos casos los efectos
sobre las mujeres embarazadas al
contrario son positivos hacemos un
llamado a que se vacunen y sobre la
fertilidad también le preguntamos
precisamente a la doctora celis y eso
fue lo que nos respondió
lo más importante es que la información
debe ser confiable y hasta el momento no
hay ningún reporte que relacione temas
de facilidad con vacunación contra el
coi es importante asegurarlo y
asegurarlo porque queremos a nuestra
población informada hablando información
cómo hacer para mantenerse informados
sobre este tema marc pues tener en
cuenta principalmente que ya hay cinco
universidades de eeuu que están
desarrollando estudios al respecto
entonces vamos a estar pendientes de los
resultados para atraerlos en el futuro
pero para mí y para todos al final la
principal conclusión es que falta
investigación una vez más alrededor del
cuerpo de las mujeres alrededor del
ciclo menstrual no puede ser que las
vacunas tengan un punto ciego como éste
así es más muchísimas gracias entonces
por toda la información el lunes más
salud en directo américa feliz fin de
semana